are you exercising well clearly not I do
very little exercise everything is true
it my whole body is turning into a sort
of a white pudding like a tapioca lovely
I'd take off my shirt if you could
handle it if you could handle the light
imbalance sure I don't you could we'll
just put a polarized lens up so we can
handle the solar I'm sure you have all
that equipment I do I got everything you
know a very jealous of yours fancy CBS
equipment we're shooting this right now
with the Hubble telescope yeah actually
we're capturing your image and infrared
great if you could forward that to my
dermatologist so I could just get myself
checked I'd be very happy uh you and I
are both gonna be celebrating our
birthdays I think in a social isolation
that yours is April eighteenth mine is
May 13th I think you have a shot really
I have a shot at like actually making
physical contact with other human beings
yes I'm being optimistic I like to be a
but you at least have a chance there's
no way we're out of isolation by April
18th which is my birthday so I'd like to
propose that all of America try and
celebrate my birthday on the 18th what
do you want what do you want what's your
shirt size well that's really nice well
I used to be a lot slimmer and I'd say
in the last week and a half I've gained
65 I'll send you a nice I'll send you a
nice shirt it'll fill some time on your
show where you open the present from me
and you have a shirt from me oh you're
gonna fill time on my show
yeah how it is now I hope so because I
really need that so what's your shirt
size Conan answer the question seven
sixteen and a half with a 39 inch sleeve
Wow I'm like an orangutan your
manspreading by the way I can see all of
you not on this camera only on your
camera that's what I'm people at home
don't know is that your camera you're
getting the floor show yes but nobody up
there can see it I am seeing everything
and my hat's off to you I'm very
impressed
thank you